in this chart right here we're giving
out scores on midterm and final exams
where the vertical axis is the score and
points and then each of these pairs of
bar charts give us for an individual
where the blue bar is for example how
ishan did on the midterm the yellow is
how he did on the final for emily the
blue is how they she did on the midterm
yellow is how she did on the final and
we have a bunch of interesting questions
here the first question what was the
median what was the median score for the
final exam so just as a review median
literally means what was the middle
score so really we should list all the
scores for the final exam and sort them
in order and then figure out what the
middle score actually was so let's look
at all the scores on final exams so
scores
scores on the final exam so you have a
hundred here ishaan got a hundred on the
final exam remember this yellow bar is
the final exam so there's a hundred
emily also got a hundred on the final
exam looks like it was an easy final
exam
daniel also got 100 on the final exam
and then let's see jessica looks like
she got a 75
75 and then william got an 80.
so if we were to sort these in order
let's say we did an increasing order you
could you could write well the lowest
score was a 75 then you have an 80 and
then you have three hundreds 100 another
100 and another hundred so there's five
scores right over here so you will have
a middle if you had an even number then
you would take the mean of the two
center of the two center values but here
you have one center value and when you
order it like this it's pretty clear
that your center value your middle value
is 100. so the median score for the
final exam is 100 and that's because you
had so many hundreds here that the
median the middle score was still a
hundred
what is the mid-range the mid-range of
the mid-term scores i'll do it in blue
on honor of the color of the bars for
the midterm so the mid-range
is the mean
of your highest and lowest scores so
let's calculate this so let's go to the
mid-range
the mid-range you could view it as the
arithmetic mean or the the average of
your highest and lowest scores so the
mid-range of midterm
of mid
term
so let's see the highest midterm score
looking at the blue the highest one is
right here so jessica got 100 on the
midterm so that's your highest score
your lowest score on the midterm looks
like this one right over here daniel got
a 60
got a 60. and so the mid-range is going
to be the mean the arithmetic mean of
these two numbers so you add 100 plus 60
divide by 2 you get 160
over 2 or 80. so this right over here is
going to be 80.
what was the average student score for
the final exam
well for that we just have to add up the
scores on the final exams and then
divide by the number of scores we have
so we might be able to do that in our
heads let's see well let's we could we
just write it over here so we have 100
plus 100 plus 100
plus 75
plus 80. so all of that divided by
all of that divided by five that'll give
us our average if someone tells you
average without giving more information
they're probably talking about the
arithmetic mean
so this is going to be 300
plus
let's see 300 plus
another 155 so it's going to be 455 over
5.
this is equal to 455
over 5.
and let's see 5 this is going to be
equal to
5 goes in let me write it down here this
is equal to 5 goes into 45 or 450 90
times and into 5 1. so this is going to
be equal to 91. so the average score for
the final exam is a 91.
what was the mode for the final exam
scores so the mode is the most common
score so once again we've listed all of
them and it's pretty clear that the most
common score here is 100 100 shows up
three times while 75 only shows up once
and an 80 only shows up once so here the
most common score is a hundred it shows
up three times
what is the range of the midterm scores
so the range is literally the difference
between the high score and the lowest
score so the high score we already
figured up and this is for the midterm
for the midterm so the highest score is
a hundred
and we're going to subtract from that
the lowest score which was a 60.
so the range is equal to 40. the
mid-range was the average of these two
things the range is just the difference
between the two so the range of the
midterm scores is
is 40 and we're done